so we're here to do the fence the best
foreign film this year over 80 different
nations submitted films to be considered
for the Oscar in this category here are
the five that rose to the top the
nominees for Best Foreign Language Film
from Denmark land of mine directed by
Martin Johnson from Sweden
a man called even directed by Dennis own
from Australia canna directed by Bentley
Dean and Martin Butler from Germany Toni
Aragon directed by Meryn Oda from Iran
the salesman directed by Oscar quality
and the Oscar goes to the salesman a car
for hockey
[Applause]
[Music]
Anusha I'm sorry we'll be accepting the
award on behalf of the director of the
salesman Asghar Farhadi
I will be reading a statement by Mustafa
Hadi
it's a great honor to be receiving this
valuable award for the second time I
would like to thank the members of the
Academy my crew in Iran by producer
Alexander Malachi cohan media Amazon and
my fellow nominees in the Foreign Film
category I'm sorry I'm not with you
tonight
my absence is out of respect for the
people of my country and those of other
six nations whom have been disrespected
by the inhumane law that bans entry of
immigrants to the US dividing the world
thank you dividing the world into the US
and our enemies categories creates fear
a deceitful justification for aggression
and war these words prevent democracy
and human rights in countries which have
themselves been victims of aggression
filmmakers can turn their cameras to
capture shared human qualities and break
stereotypes of various nationalities and
religions these they create empathy
between us and others an empathy which
we need today more than ever thank you
on behalf of mr. Farhadi
thank you